even tea breaks are treacherous here
the troops barely Flinch hardened by
months of War
with the front line quite literally
freezing they focus on different
priorities
to a point
that one was too near he says though
they still don't move
just above here so we're staying now
we all head for better cover the Russian
Artillery round slammed down for nearly
half an hour
we've had to take shelter because there
was too much incoming going on outside
we're not allowed to film well we are at
the moment but while we've been sitting
here we've heard explosions
up above making this whole shelter
shudder it's pretty terrifying and this
is what the soldiers have to go through
finally we're able to escape a tense
scramble
then away leaving the danger behind
earlier in the day the troops had been
showing us their trenches near the town
of bakmut where some of the fiercest
fighting is Raging this is where the
ukrainians are digging in their
defensive line the problem is as the
weather gets colder the ground freezes
and it becomes much harder to dig and
the front line keeps on moving
but these are motivated men
the sound of war is almost constant as
Ukraine tries to Halt attempts by Russia
to seize bakmut
the battle is described as a hellish
meat grinder foreign
but the ukrainians are paying a heavy
price as well
the commander shows us where rounds hit
the previous two days killing one of his
soldiers we're told that the temperature
here goes to minus 30 in January and
February are your guys going to keep
fighting in that cold weather or will
you pause and wait for the spring
its defense now a dual challenge against
the elements and the enemy even the
trees no longer provide top cover
tough too for those still living nearby
Ukraine has enjoyed some key victories
in recent months
but the winter War awaits
their brain Sky News in eastern Ukraine